sure
[Music]
well good evening everybody on behalf of
the Q Society of Australia it's my
pleasure to welcome you all here tonight
and to extend a very warm welcome as we
just have to our special guest Mr Robert
Spencer who's come all the way from
America and he's here for the very first
time that we're so looking forward to
hearing from him my name is Vicki Jansen
and I'm the deputy president of the Q
Society the organizing body behind this
Robert Spencer tour um it's been made
possible through both generous
sponsorship and the many sacrifices of C
Society members and supporters to whom
we're all very grateful um we all know
there's no such thing as a free lunch
and none knows us better than our very
generous lunch sponsors uh their
sponsorship has subsidized uh the public
meetings to make them affordable for all
and so thank you very much to all those
who are involved in those special
lunches and it would be very negligent
of me not to particularly mention our
president Jeff Dixon who has worked
tirelessly up here to make this all
possible and we appreciate all the
efforts of all the people and supporters
um in in Queensland now before we go any
further it's unfortunately necessary for
me to read a legal announcement which in
itself highlights one of the major
concerns facing free democracies so
please note Victoria's racial and
religions tolerate tolerance act 2001
otherwise known as Victoria's blasphemy
law is a serious concern for Q society
as we are Incorporated in Victoria this
law may even apply to statements made in
other states and while we find this law
abhorent because it prohibits free
speech and advances
totalitarianism we respect that the rule
of law is a fundamental Australian value
and we affirm that in accordance with
Section 11 of the racial and religion
tolerance act which permits conduct
engaged in reasonably and in good faith
in the course of any statement
publication discussion or debate made or
held or any other conduct engaged in uh
for any purpose that is in the public
interest or in making or publishing a
fair and accurate report of any event or
matter of public interest that Q Society
does does ACT reasonably and in good
faith and there is little need to
discuss whether the topic of Islam is in
the public interest we do not encourage
or incite others to feel hatred
revulsion contempt or ridicule of
Muslims and breach of the racial and
religion tolerance act however we will
discuss Islam including its legal code
Sharia law and the Islamic political
cultural economic social or religious
practices that we genuinely believe seek
to undermine personal freedom and
Australian values nor do we seek to
generalize about Muslims and so will not
generalize that just because some
Muslims are successful and integrated
that there is nothing to worry about at
all if there are problems in certain
sections of the Muslim Community we will
discuss these as we would discuss
problems in any other group if anyone in
the audience feels that's very
subjective feels emotions of anger or of
being incited or provoked into negative
feelings against Muslims because our
speakers tonight refer to passages of
Islamic scripture history or the conduct
of certain Muslims in a critical manner
then we would ask that you please leave
this venue and stop reading our
material you are welcome of course to
speak to a q Society member afterwards
to who can assist in explaining the
context in which we discuss Islam
finally if anyone in the audience has
come for the purpose of deliberately
claiming offense as part of a
premeditated legal action against Q
Society or without genuine good faith
intentions then please also leave now
you have been put on notice that your
presence is simply a provocation and
incitement to us thank you for your
attention that's a bit sad isn't it we
have to say that but there you go well
we advertise this two with the theme
sociopolitical Jihad Conquering the West
without swords guns or bombs and quite
frankly who needs them while I Was
preparing for tonight an old say popped
into my head that be familiar to many
actually it said in two ways there's
more than one way to skin a rabbit and
more than one way to skin a cat but I
think we all agree doesn't matter which
way we do it it's not looking good for
the animal so likewise there is more
than one way to undermine democracy the
rule of law Freedom order the
institutions that we have the values and
the open culture that Democratic
societies enjoy having sat in numerous
Islamic lectures in Australia I'm aware
that there are individuals who may not
necessarily support the means of
terrorists yet there is growing support
for their ultimate goal to see Islam
rise politically legally and culturally
there is if you like violent and
nonviolent means to the same end of
promoting Sharia law and the Islamic
State concept I I often say dawa and
Jihad are two sides to the same coin
dawa being the peaceful invitation to
accept the Islamic narrative no matter
what way the co coin Falls both da and
Jihad effectively do the same job and
it's heads up for Islamic Sharia uh
either way unlike totalitarian regimes
democracy by nature is very
accommodating to this peaceful pillaging
of society it's not just the Muslim
Brotherhood who have a documented
strategy of what they call
civilizational Jihad in 1980 the Islamic
Council of Europe published a book
titled Muslim communities in non-muslim
states which outlined a strategy for the
Muslim Community on how to resist
assimilation and become a majority so
this is not just a conspiracy of a few
you know radical people or an ideal of
some but it is a documented strategy and
with at least 85 to 100 Sharia courts in
Britain U Muslim Enclave and noo zones
for non-muslims in many parts of Europe
we can see how successful that this
strategy has actually been Danish
psychologist Nikolai senos describes
this resistance to integration as a kind
of cultural osmosis where Western values
don't quite penetrate the Islamic World
while islamization diffuses from the
Muslim Community into non-muslim
societies but what of Australia we keep
hearing well it's different down under
opposition spokesman on sorry on
immigration Scott Morrison in a recent
address said this and I quote I do not
see the experience of Europe on IM
immigration as a prophecy for our own
future in Australia while I empath I
heard that laugh while I empathize with
the comments of Angela Merkel and David
Cameron as they battle with these
questions in a European context their
immigration practice has followed a very
different path to to Australia
unquote so it appears that successful
integration is to be attributed to our
immigration practice something dependent
upon Australian process rather than
Islamic strategy which seems to be
irrelevant I can assure you having
attended numerous Islamic lectures in
Australia the same strategy in Europe is
alive and well here my husband Mike and
I attended one at the Melbourne
University in 2008 where Dr Abdullah
hakeim quick assured the audience that
there is no no Clash of civilizations
just a rise and fall of
civilizations and quick noted that the
decline of Western power and the rise of
Islam would First Take Shape socially
and then politically sociopolitical
Jihad that was their theology so this is
an Islamic expectation and as we look
around Australia we see it as a growing
reality these comments were followed by
some from shik Shri who said that
Australia was a young country and yet to
cement its Heritage and identity and of
course the inference was that Islam
would provide this
C well how are we going is the evidence
pointing towards the Scott Morrison
narrative or the shake chry one earlier
this year I had a visit to mes
University to discuss this little book
Salam mes I don't know if any of you saw
the article by um yeah Miranda
deine and we had a little chat about
that now while we're all hearing um
about social inclusion in Australia lot
you know with lots of public money
throwing at that cause this booklet
essentially advises Muslims how they can
avoid integration all together it
directs them not just to Muslim
institutions mosques prayer centers and
some of them are very dubious at that it
directs them to Islamic Publications
Islamic websites Islamic schools and
other miscellaneous services and food
Outlets but also it directs them to
Muslim medical and dental practitioners
non-muslim practitioners will not be
getting a slice of this business simply
based on their lack of adherence to the
Islamic faith now if anyone else did
that it would be called
discrimination isn't that strange this
blatant preferencing of Muslim only
medical and dental practitioners
practitioners obviously Falls far short
of Notions of the real social cohesion
now all this is quite interesting given
that on the students rights page in this
booklet it's noted that exclus including
or isolating a person is a form of
bullying well if the whole booklet
appears to exclude non-muslim
Australians and if any of our
International students thought they
might be tempted to taste a little bit
of Freedom while they're here in
Australia and choose for themselves what
to wear what to attend or what to eat I
mean after all the Quran does say the
food of the people of the book is lawful
for Muslims which makes it all quite
relevant there is a note in the monach
Muslim Students handbook reminding them
it is the responsibility of each
individual to be vigilant guess what it
says to be vigilant in making sure that
the food they consume is halal now this
is a public university mandating
vigilance that seems a bit like bullying
to me and then there's the Halal
helpline of course noted for any
desperate
situations sorry we mustn't mock one
can't help but wonder if Malaysian
author say akar is right in his
assessment that the Halal industry is
all a great burden upon people a burden
that we're not really alleviating for
them here in Australia it's part of a
huge commercial industry driven by
islamist profiteers now if people are
coming to Australia for a bit of Freedom
it's going to be very difficult for them
when we keep validating all these
practices so let me ask a question in
good faith a question that any
reasonable person might ask how do we
expect integration shared culture values
and law when we promote segregation well
we can't share the same food Finance
doctors dentists Public Services
swimming pools and other public space
the Trove university has its Muslim only
toilets and prayer rooms the group oie
Muslims is campaigning for exclusively
Muslim prayer rooms in a wa Hospital on
the basis that they need to avoid the
idolatry that may occur if they share
that was in their
submission our public schools are
adapting to a Muslim perspectives
curriculum project where among many
other things not just female School
swimming is recommended for the Muslim
Students but Muslim only swimming I
would call that an aparte practice
wouldn't you some public schools are
catering to this diversity by ensuring
TX shops are exclusively Halal well
that's very diverse no more ham
sandwiches or bacon bits for these kids
and there are calls for legal pluralism
by the peak Islamic body effort the
Australian Federation of Islamic
councils his openly advertises its
three-point methodology on how to
overturn democracy and impose the
Islamic State seditious circulating
booklets like this democracy is a system
of kufer the Infidel and actually in
that booklet it forbids support of
democracy and the rule of law we picked
that up in Sydney and the government has
committed Australia to support Sharia
finance and innovation of the Muslim
Brotherhood to undermine Western
economies we have a Sydney Council who's
been boycotting Israel and a Melbourne
Council employing a Muslim Outreach
officer to educate the community about
Islam because that's what we all need
and all this with public
money and to give substance to our
concerns the recent report by legal
academics Anne black and Cary sadik
finds that a system of pluralism based
on Sharia law abounds in Australia so
that's the official report it abounds
already a system endorsing polygamist
and underage marriages in contravention
of The Marriage Act on and on and on it
goes the social and legal framework for
little Islamic states in the making
popping up everywhere perhaps as Mr
Morrison claims our selective
immigration policies are more robust
than Europe however our social policies
appear to be hitting Us in exactly the
same direction and to ignore the social
cost will be to our own Peril because
you know I don't think of us wants to be
that skinned rabbit it would be an
oversight to only mention the challenge
of this peaceful pling of Western
society when reports confirm there's
also an over representation in violent
crime suggesting the fostering of a
culture of violence now that's not
something we're normally allowed to say
but in a report by Phyllis Chesler uh
it's noted that in Europe
96% of the perpetrators of honor
killings we're talking about Europe are
Muslims and allegation of unacceptable
westernization accounted for 71% of
these crimes in Europe and 91% in North
America so the reason these girls were
killed was because of unacceptable
westernization in a western
country bad attitudes towards things
Western abound and building up Islam
rather than a healthy respect for
Western freedoms and Western Law May
ultimately convert these bad attitudes
into bad actions we don't see a lot of
figures published here but actually the
age recently reported that in 2008
42% of the clients of the Australian
Muslim women Center for human rights
reported domestic abuse that's 42% but
last year that figure Rose to
80% of the Muslim women now that's a
very sad thing in Australia hilling is
just the extreme end of domestic abuse
and inadvertently promoting Sharia in
any form is a Reckless Pursuit on part
of De uh democratic governments we all
know there's a door in and no door out
there is it's universally agreed about
these apostasy laws so promoting Islam
at all is a reckless pursuit of any
government so to conclude I'd like to
highlight that this is essentially a
battle of ideas manifesting at the
extreme end in terrorism not only are we
engaged in an asymmetric War militarily
but the ideological battle is also an
asymmetric one while pastors of course
one of them's in the room tonight Pastor
Scott has been taken before the courts
accused of mocking and fify Islam the
spokesman for the Islamic Council of
Victoria he's he's a partner in the
comedy act fear of brown Planet he
received a government grant to Mock and
vilify white people and non-muslims
150,00
I believe so non-muslims get fined and
you know taken before the courts for
this mocking and vilifying while Muslims
get public grants because comedy is good
for mental health that was a Vic Health
Grant and when I attended the vcat
hearing to stand with Pastor Scott um as
they stood accused on this fif
vilification charge there were two burer
clad women at the back of the uh hearing
one day and when judge Higgins entered
the room everyone stood you know to as
you do to acknowledge the judge they
would not stand they remained seated and
we were overheard saying we won't stand
for an Infidel judge that was in a
vilification hearing and that just makes
a complete mockery of it and I was quite
amazed to read the argument of the
defense lawyer of the Muslim who called
the Australian Jewish soldier who
returned from Afghanistan and I quote a
dirty animal a thousand times worse than
a pig and his lawyer in his defense said
the alleged comments were made in a
political context and were not
necessarily
offensive and then the barister added
insults are a legitimate part of the
political
discourse interesting isn't it if the
word Muslim was substituted for the word
Jew would any lawyer be G to uphold that
argument absolutely not well that's a
little bit about where we are in
Australia don't give
up there will be time for questions at
the end of the evening but now it's my
pleasure to ask Warren Raymond where's
Warren OH get Warren and he's another q
Society board member and he's um going
to give us a few insights into Europe
just before I introduce our main speaker
and special guest Robert spener thanks
Warren that was great thank you ladies
and gentlemen for turning out in such
great numbers um uh to defend freedom
and democracy in
Australia um it's been a hectic tour and
it's been a very uh interesting
year in earlier this year um the Ivory
Coast as anybody ever heard the Ivory
Coast Ivory Coast fell to Islam I think
they had something like 20% Muslims and
U the fact that they burned about
thousand Christians and and a church um
made it clear from the beginning mean
that uh the American Administration the
Obama regime let's call it Obama regime
that's what it is uh and the clintons
always helpful to bring
uh uh freedom and democracy to the
Muslim nations uh to accept it to accept
it to legitimize it so we have now
another Muslim nation in Africa and the
same the Jihad rag in in rages in
Nigeria and in many other places and
always in about 30 theaters of War uh
around the world ladies and gentlemen I
left Europe when I was a young man and I
returned some years later to find myself
in eurabia have you ever heard of
eurabia well you know Europe slept and
slept around and everybody had a lot of
fun and they forgot to produce children
so this is what the problem is nowadays
uh we when I look around everywhere we
go we see aging populations and no kids
and to make up for this we see
increasing numbers of Muslims who make
up for uh this deficit and this is
totally in in line with what our
governments expect us to to
accept
so that time everybody had uh was
aspiring in the early ' 70s everybody
was aspiring to have a good car a better
house a job and um so in the meantime
our
law is being changed the Socialists are
advancing and uh you may know about
German
Grier anybody knows German Grier you
ever heard of German Grier she just
she's one of these spiritual Seekers you
know she's still looking for herself
somewhere in India at the moment and uh
she said um it's too bad that we can't
have Marxism without
Sharia so
oh um so she changed you know the the
bra burners from then and where uh they
are now looking for the burka it looks
like it seems to be the case I want to
tell you a few things about France
France has 850 noo zones and um I was
there I happened to be there um in
Strasburg some six or seven years ago
when uh Muslim musl Allah abbar
screaming Muslims were burning the cars
in front of the uh Hotel where I was
staying in
Strasburg they burned all over France
about 10,000 cars 400 bus 400 businesses
and I don't know how many buses and some
buses with people
inside the
French uh government you know Zaki Zaki
is so-called right winger is one he's a
person who believes that you cannot
defend yourself in your own home with a
weapon this is uh um something I find a
little bit disturbing for a right winger
and he was very strong he called them
raal which means
RAB and um of course the Muslims
complained and they complained also to
rubert Murdoch Who U instantly rubert
Murdoch news corporation you know who
rert Murdoch you have never heard of
rert Mur okay good but he happens to be
uh financed by a Saudi prince who called
him and said please change it instantly
to youths they are not Muslim riots they
are youth riots and they corrected it
and they also built these youths who ran
away from the police who had stolen the
car and hold themselves up in a power in
a building that where there was a power
generator uh they were electrocuted
that's why the riot started originally
they were there were two youth they had
a stolen car they ran away they were
holed up in a in a Powerhouse and then
they were electrocuted and uh the police
was blamed the police was dragged in
front of the courts after that the two
policemen that CH that were chasing them
were brought on brought to trial so I
mean it's it's uh it's all a bit
confusing isn't it and then they built
them a monument and nowadays the both
parties in France the so-called left and
the so-called right they're going there
and they put they put flowers there to
honor these unfortunate youths who
happen to be
killed so it's a bit uh
strange a few months later after this
incident I happened to find myself in
Guam where I had a business and I met a
Frenchman who just came back from a from
an extended holiday in
Tahiti and we were talking and he said
oh you know I asked him about the
islamization of France and he said oh
it's no problem no problem it's all good
um I said you don't worry you have no
problem I mean 10,000 car burn 10,000
cars burned and huge disaster for the
economy and everything he said no it's
good it's very good said it's very good
for business I said what business are
you in he said he's a car
dealer so I mean there's like Vicki said
there's different ways to skin a
cat you can you know I mean it's the
same thing when I had uh I had a little
problem while ago uh with an Iman he was
offended because I opposed the mosque
and directag me through the paper and I
shouldn't have the right to freedom of
speech my there was a website where I
posted this apparently is very offensive
to
Muslims nobody left uh so I I suspect
there are no Muslims here nobody against
freedom of speech okay anyway so what
happened was uh the IMA became very uh
irritated in these negotiations that we
had to engage in so we're facing off
against each other and um the Imam
became very aggravated and he said um
you want to stop Islam you cannot stop
Islam nobody can stop Islam Islam is
like a
tsunami sorry tsunami I said well
tsunami is a natural disaster isn't
it natural disaster
so so so I said uh but that means is is
isn't it a man-made
disaster so that wasn't exactly uh
soothing for his NES I can tell you but
there was again there was a way out of
this and there are many ways to skin a
cat like Vick said uh there's also some
good news because Ezra leant who had
similar Problems by when he published
the cartoons the Muhammed cartoons have
you ever heard of the mamons okay um
Esra in Canada uh is a young man is a
lawyer and he has a mouth he can talk
and he uh videotaped the mediation
sessions with one of these human rights
um what you star Chambers star Chambers
where Inquisition basically that we face
when we say anything negative about
Islam we have to face these star
Chambers and um they have 100%
conviction rate is that right or had at
least the 100% conviction rate until
that happened but but Esra want taped
all this and um
succeeded
in U winning it winning it and because
of this he brought all these uh things
out in the open uh the freedom of speech
laws which were very oppressive in
Canada hate speech laws are going to be
repealed it looks like it at least I
won't I wouldn't hold my breath but um
uh the Steven Haro the PM in Canada he's
it looks like he's bringing it back to
Parliament to be disgusted at least and
to be abolished so that's uh we can all
do our part we can all help to make a
change and change we must
otherwise everything that our uh
generations and generations of our
people fought for freedom of speech
human rights will be lost yeah that's so
I give it back to Vicki who in will
introduce Our Guest for tonight Robert
spener who came extra from America we
had a wonderful tour this is the last
evening
ladies and gentlemen big welcome
to we've had a lot of fun on this tour I
I must say and uh yeah we've had a lot
of fun we've got to know each other so
look it is my pleasure now to introduce
to our special guest Mr Robert Spencer
um you know it's often said you need to
know when you're in a battle you need to
know the enemy now Muslim people um not
necessarily the enemy but the Islamic
ideology is an enemy to the state to
freedom to Human Rights and to the rule
of law so let's not pretend that it
isn't it is and there's uh you know I've
been really impressed I've been to two
radio stations now with Robert to listen
to him answer questions and I'm he's
really that's his gift and he's just
it's been amazing to listen to the depth
of knowledge his expertise and we're
just really blessed to have him here
tonight so Robert's going to share with
us he's previously um presented to the
US Central Command the US Army command
asymmetric Warfare group the FBI The
Joint terrorism task force is the author
of 10 books on the subject including the
New York Times bestsellers the truth
about Muhammad and the politically
incorrect guy to
Islam and of course he's the director of
the website Jihad watch which uh you
know informs people about what is
actually going on and there's not many
um websites that you get the accurate
information so look we uh all this
stands in testimony to his courage and
his commitment to freedom of speech and
so we're just so happy to have him here
tonight and as I say we and also he's a
really nice
guy you know as well so welcome Mr
Roberts thank you so much for that warm
welcome and thank you for coming I'm uh
very glad to see that there are people
who are concerned about these issues and
I thought that since uh I actually just
read in a local paper right before I
came here that uh there's a local
politician I'm sorry I don't remember
his name but he has uh asked his party
and some local authorities to condemn
the Q Society for uh resisting Sharia
and for having me speak and so I thought
that as long as I'm here in the process
of giving offense I just give right away
and get that part out of the way and so
here you ready here we are uh there was
a young Muslim boy in my of my
acquaintance about four or five years
old and he was in the supermarket with
his mother but he got separated from her
and so he was crying he was all upset
and uh he finally they took him to the
manager of the supermarket and he said
uh what does your mother look like and
he said I have no idea
now maybe you found that
offensive and that is actually the point
the point is when we have a law such as
the law that required Vicki to read that
disclaimer at the beginning this
ridiculous law that you have in the
state of Victoria that Pastor Scott ran
a foul of by telling the truth the law
Outlaws it forbids giving offense
but giving offense is of course entirely
within the power of the person who is
offended to choose not to be offended to
choose some other reaction if you came
up to me right now and you said you know
you're a racist islamophobic anti-muslim
bigot I I might be
offended but I might not be I might
think well you're an idiot or I might
think you don't you're ignorant and you
have no idea about these issues or I
might burst into tears and run from the
room or any or I might call the Human
Rights Commission but the any number of
things that I could do I do not have to
take offense it is not required it is
not an automatic or necessary reaction
to anything Absolut and so
obviously this is an elementary point
that everyone knows you know sticks and
stones may break my bones but names will
never hurt me you know our mothers told
us that you don't have to be offended
when people call you names or they say
something you don't like they told you
they told me so what happened did they
not tell these politicians did they have
deficient
mothers obviously they know they know
what they're doing and what they're
doing is granting hegemony granting a
particularly privileged status to
Muslims in
Victoria because the person who decides
what is hate speech the person who
decides what is offensive in some spirly
objective
evaluation is the one who has the power
to control the public
discourse the one who can decide that
something really is offensive and needs
to be prosecuted as such is a privileged
class who has an ability to withstand
criticism because you're not allowed to
give him any and this is the reason why
in our civilization
Western judeo-christian Civilization
such as has been elaborated in Australia
and in the United States of America and
in
Europe we have freedom of speech to
begin with because people realized that
it was the fundamental bullwark our
strongest Safeguard against a tyrannical
ruler running rough shot over the will
of the people by being able to stifle
descend and because
the founders of our Nations knew that
descent was essential to the body
politic in order to protect us from
tyranny they instituted freedom of
speech freedom of speech is precisely in
order that the laws protecting freedom
of speech that is such as still
exist they are precisely designed for
offensive speech for speech that
somebody might find offensive for speech
that bothers people that bothers tyrants
that bother others those who want to
perpetrate an agenda under the noses of
others without being stopped without
having it being pointed out to them what
is being done so that there can be
resistance and so when that's
gone then forget it all bets are off not
only that but when Victoria instituted
this anti-freedom of speech law and of
course that's just one you know Canada
has them as as as Warren was talking
about and the United States of America
even even though we have the first
amendment that protects freedom of
speech the First Amendment to the
Constitution the Obama Administration
actually joined with the government of
Egypt in the summer of 2009 to
co-sponsor a non-binding resolution at
the United Nations that called upon
member States to criminalize religious
defamation and insults and denigration
of vilification of religions but of
course says who is it vilification you
know all these years I've been doing
this and people say you hate Muslims you
hate Islam and so on and I I constantly
think of a quote from St Paul in the New
Testament have I become your enemy by
telling you the
truth and if if the truth is
vilification we're in big trouble but
the law in Victoria and the Obama
Administration joining at the UN with
Egypt to call upon member States to
criminalize religious hatred or
vilification the Canada hate speech laws
and all similar laws everywhere else
they are
coincidentally absolutely in line with
Islamic laws Provisions regarding what
is permissible for non-muslims to say
about Islam and how they must behave
with respect toward it in the Islamic
State what a
coincidence isn't that funny that uh the
laws would be designed and the laws
would be largely used only or almost
only by a group that also has a legal
system and a system for society and
governance that forbids and denies the
freedom of
speech but of course that was the whole
point that's why the organization of the
is of Islamic cooperation Formerly Known
until recently as the organization of
the Islamic conference which is 57
Muslim governments 56 States and the
Palestinian Authority uh the largest
voting block at the United Nations today
that's why they have been pushing at the
UN for laws that would restrict the
freedom of speech Not only would such
laws render us mute and thus defenseless
in the face of the advancing Jihad
whether that Jihad be violent or
nonviolent but also Al they are part of
a larger program to bring Islamic law to
our societies and to force it upon us
and under the guise of sensitivity to
minorities and a desire
to resist racism even though Islam is
not a race and there are Muslims of all
Races who are pursuing this agenda the
authorities in
Victoria happily aided in their agenda
of implementing bringing elements of
Islamic law
here now of course they have no clue
that that was the agenda they have no
idea that that was what was going on
because of course they don't know
anything about Islam except what they
have been told by smooth and smiling
deceivers
and also they know that these people are
victims who are being discriminated
against and who therefore need special
treatment so that they can enjoy the
protections of our society now of course
the Discrimination is spous just as much
as the rest of it I can tell you that
the latest FBI statistics for hate
crimes in the United States are just the
same as FBI statistics for hate crimes
in the United States every year Muslims
are down at the bottom of the list
nobody's really bothering them and yet
hate crimes against Jews are right at
the top of the list and yet how and I
expect that it's probably the same way
much the same way here and yet how much
do you read about islamophobia versus a
resurgent
anti-Semitism not only that but the
Muslims have made this agenda abundantly
clear it isn't as if they have been shy
about telling us what their intentions
are they've been perfectly clear about
it they've been perfectly forthright
about it and yet the authority still
they they somehow Miss it it's as if
they have their fingers in their ear and
they're saying la la la la
la the Quran the holy book of Islam the
teachings of Muhammad the prophet of
Islam the elaborations of those
teachings by Islamic jurist prudence and
by the various sects and schools of
Islam they all agree all of them without
exception all of the mainstream Orthodox
sects of Islam all of the schools of
jurist
prudence the teachings of Muhammad in
the Hadith the traditions of his words
and deeds which are normative for
Islamic law and practice and the Quran
itself they all agree that it is part of
the responsibility of the Muslim
Community to wage war against
non-muslims and to subjugate them as
inferiors under the rule of Islamic
law this is part of the program that
absolutely upfront about it I'll show
you I was in London a while ago and
while I was there you know I was a
little bit of a vacation I visited
mosques and
uh you know what else was there to see
in
London and so and I let you in I yeah
well I didn't tell them I was
coming anyway uh so I was in London
going to mosqu and I went to the
Finsbury Park Mosque which you may have
heard of because it was the Mosque of
Abu Hamza al-- musri who uh is known
popularly as Captain Hook he was an Imam
at the Finsbury Park Mosque in London
who uh in an excess of piety one day
while he was making a holy Islamic bomb
he uh it accidentally detonated and he
lost an eye in a hand and so he has a
hook for a hand and that's hence his
nickname uh but in any case Captain Hook
is gone now he he he uh was famous for
saying things like uh one time he said
in a sermon uh at this SP Park Mosque
that the kafar that's us the unbelievers
or at least most of us uh are like
cattle and you can catch them you can uh
milk them financially you can kill them
you can do whatever you want with them
they're yours uh and he acted on this so
he was involved in various Terror plots
and so on and now he's in prison so I
went into the Finsbury Park Mosque a
little after all this happened and uh
they were very nice and they didn't they
didn't know that I what I do for work
work but in any case I uh uh was
accosted by a young man who was very
happy to see me uh because I was not a
Muslim and he he weighed me down with
books to convert me to Islam and one of
them was this Quran which is a very nice
edition of the Quran as I'll explain in
a moment and I asked him uh I hear that
there's been some trouble here I hear
that you had some difficulty with some
of the earlier uh leadership and he said
oh yes yes yes uh there were some
extremists but they're all gone now and
everybody here now is peaceful and
moderate and he gave me this peaceful
moderate
Quran and uh it's really very helpful
because this Quran has context in it
have you ever noticed that whenever
somebody like me or maybe somebody like
you whenever you quote the Quran it's
always out of context I never have
managed to quote the Quran in
context you know uh like for example
slay the unbelievers wherever you find
them which is chapter 2 where 191 4:89
and chapter 9:5 it's three times in
there uh I've never quoted that in
context but I do Wonder have you ever
wondered what would be a context
of I mean unless it said here's what you
better not do right before that but it
doesn't anyway
so I get this Quran and it's got context
written by S Abul Mali now maudi was a
Pakistani uh Theologian and politician
he was the founder of jamaat islami
which is still the largest Islamic
supremacist Pro Sharia party in Pakistan
and Milana maudi as he was known uh
Milana is a is an honorific title uh
that shows that he was a very wise man
uh he died in 1979 but he was he was
a really extraordinary writer and his
writings are found anywhere if you go to
your local Islamic bookstore and I know
you probably all have an account there
and just uh ask them for the writings of
maludy they will probably show you that
they have his multivolume commentary on
the Quran and maybe some other things he
made a brilliant speech about the theory
of jihad which is frequently republished
and his uh commentary on the Quran is
digested in this handy one volume Quran
with
context now maudi is as mainstream as
you can get he's as a matter of fact the
University of Southern California which
is not as far as I know a Sharia state
or an Islamic uh madrasa it the Muslim
Students Association there several years
back they set up a very handy uh
searchable online Quran and Hadith
collection it's interesting to note that
uh a few years later they changed its
name to the Center for Muslim Jewish
engagement and took out the search
function recently and I think why are
they making it less useful unless maybe
they don't really want you to see what's
in there but anyway um they had
commentary by maudi on that site until
they started to uh clean it all up and
maludy is internationally respected
internationally influential very
mainstream so the verse remember that
we've been discussing about the it's
part of the core program of Islam to
subjugate us to deny us basic rights and
to establish Muslims as a privileged
class who have rights that the
non-muslims do not enjoy now think about
that in light of the Free Speech laws or
the anti-free speech laws they establish
Muslims as a special class who have
rights that we do not
enjoy no because you know you can insult
and vilify me all day but there's no way
the court would take the case would it
but
my goodness if somebody would didn't
like that joke then you know they'll be
leading me out of here in handcuffs so
anyway chapter 9 verse 29 of the Quran
is the foundation for this idea that
Muslims must have rights and privileges
that non-muslims do not have and it goes
like this it goes something like this
fight against those who do not believe
in Allah and his do not obey Allah and
his messenger and do not forbid what he
has forbidden even if they are of the
people of the book that's us the people
of of the book is the quran's
designation for primarily Jews and
Christians also zoroastrians and some
others fight against those who do not
obey a law and his messenger and do not
forbid what he has forbidden even if
they are of the people of the book until
they pay the gizia which is a tax with
willing submission and feel themselves
subdued until they pay the gizia a tax
that non-muslims pay in the Islamic
State and Muslims are exempt from paying
with willing submission and feel
themselves subdued well of course there
I've just done it again I just quoted
the book out of context but luckily I
have my moderate peaceful Quran from the
Finsbury Park Mosque After All the
Troubles were over and it's got context
from molana Mali himself so let's
go sorry I had it bookmarked but the
bookmark is gone from that one
page the purpose for which Muslims are
required to fight is not as one might
think to compel the unbelievers into
embracing Islam well that's a
relief the purpose is not to compel us
into embracing Islam after all we hear
in another verse that is oft quoted by
television commentators and Islamic
spokesmen there is no compulsion in
religion chapter 2 verse 256 so it's not
to force us it's not to compel us to
embrace Islam so what what is it for
rather its purpose that is the purpose
for which Muslims are required to fight
its purpose is to put an end to the
suarin the rule of the unbelievers so
that the latter are unable to rule over
people people I mean not just some
people all people all
people that's you see that's an
extraordinary revolutionary statement is
saying as Mali himself actually puts it
just so that we keep this in context Mal
he puts it in his larger multivolume
commentary on the Quran he says this and
I quote non-muslims have absolutely no
right to wield the Reigns of power in
any part of God's Earth and if they do
the Believers are under the obligation
to dislodge them from That Power by any
means
possible so here he says the authority
to rule should only be vested
only be vested in those who follow the
true Faith that's Islam for those of you
who are just joining us unbelievers who
do not follow this true Faith should
live in a state of
subordination and that state of
subordination is called
Victoria the unbelievers have to live in
a state of
subordination that is the premise and
the principle and the foundation of the
sociopolitical Jihad
and it's happening right under our noses
right
now the purpose of a free speech law
that makes it a crime to offend Muslims
obviously establishes Muslims as having
rights and privileges that non-muslims
do not
have the purpose of all the stealth
Jihad initiatives is the same it is not
just to win accommodation for Muslim
practices
it proceeds by claiming that it's all
about trying to win accommodation for
Muslim
practices but that is clearly not the
only agenda I'll give you an example the
JB Swift company is a meat packing
company in the United States and it has
plants in Nebraska and Colorado among
other places and in those plants both of
them it has imported huge numbers by the
hundreds some mes to come into the
plants and
work so that in each of those plants
about half of the
workforce is Muslim Somali Muslim
immigrants and the other half are
non-muslims so in both of these plants
the Muslim workers started walking off
the job when it was time for prayers the
five daily prayers and of course you're
talking about mass production
you're talking about what's essentially
an assembly line in the modern form such
that there is very precise timing for
the jobs that have to be done and
they're gone they're walking away so
everything gets fouled up fouled up with
a W because he chicken
anyway
then they of course were fired and of
course they
sued and of course they
won because the United States has the
equal employment opportunity commission
which mandates that that businesses have
the responsibility to make reasonable
accommodation of particular religious
practices and so they declared that
giving these guys breaks for prayers was
reasonable accommodation for particular
religious practices end of story except
it wasn't then what happened nobody
expected then then what happened was
that the non-muslim employees complained
and it was really great because they
were all Black and Hispanic and so
nobody could say oh they're
racists but
anyway they complained because they were
having to work longer days to make up
for these guys disruption of the
schedule and their special
breaks and so they were saying now
you're discriminating against
us you have placed Muslims in a special
privileged position and they have rights
and privileges that the non-muslim
employees do not have you got to convert
to Islam to get those
breaks now
see that's exactly the agenda that's
exactly the point because remember the
passage remember the verse and remember
how Mali put it in context that
non-muslims must live in a state of
subordination
the verse says they have to pay the tax
the jiza with willing submission and
feel themselves subdued an Islamic law
elaborates throughout history a
remarkable
detailed way list of ways in which the
non-muslims have to feel their state of
subordination because you see the
Muslims have the responsibility to bring
about the just and perfect Society on
Earth
that's their job they've been given that
by God the Quran says you are the best
of
people among the nations of the earth
it's chapter 3: 110 by contrast the
unbelievers are the most vile of created
beings that's chapter 98:6 so which one
should rule in a
society obviously the Believers the best
of people should rule the society
according to the law of Allah and the
unbelievers should live those vile of
the most vile of created beings must
live in a state of
subordination if they are not living in
a state of subordination the Muslims
have the responsibility to put them
there that's what it said fight against
the people of the book until they pay
the gizia with willing submission and
feel themselves subdued so
we see it
happening exactly in the way that they
have planned it the meat packing plant
gave the Muslims the break times but you
see the point was not the break time at
all the point was that they have rights
and privileges that the non-muslims
don't have and so the non-muslims are
living in a state of
subjugation they do not have the rights
that the Muslims have in prisons in
London
there are young men who are converting
to Islam in the prisons now of course
there's a targeted effort in England and
in the United States and I suspect
probably here also to convert people in
prison to Islam but this is not
that they're young men converting to
Islam in prison because you get better
food because you get halal
food and you know prison food I nobody
goes to prison to to to because the food
is good and yet when you start getting
in catered meals that are that are
carefully Halal and it really does
improve significantly in quality and
here again Muslims have special
privileges that non-muslims do not have
that's the whole idea of dimude of the
state of subjugation that the
non-muslims live in the idea is that
because we have rebelled because we have
rejected the truth of Muhammad and Islam
then we have to be made to
feel punishment for that in this life
and in the next in the next of course
we'll all burn in hell but before that
they have to work to subjugate us and
because that is part of the
establishment you see of the perfectly
just society in which the truth shines
forth and those who reject the truth
those vile created beings they are
subordinate but the thing about this
is that the state of
subordination that is mandated is
also sorry
second now where were
we yes state of subordination Victoria
the Muslims you see are the executors of
God's Wrath in this way in a way that
the judeo-christian tradition does not
allow for the idea that vengeance is
mine says the Lord and I will repay and
the idea of course that there can be no
perfect Human Society on Earth these are
things that we take for granted in the
west and that we understand in the
context of the judeo Christian tradition
these things are completely at variance
with Islam in Islam the perfect Society
is established and maintained by A Reign
of Terror and that perfect Society
features Muslims having rights and
privileges that non-muslims do not have
and the idea of that you see this state
of
subjugation is designed to bring us all
in to
Islam Muhammad the prophet of Islam he
said when you meet the unbelievers
invite them to accept Islam that's dawa
prizing invite them to accept Islam if
they refuse invite them to pay viiza
that's the tax in other words invite
them to enter the Islamic social order
as inferiors if they refuse both of
those seek a Law's help and go to war
conversion subjugation or
War but the idea of the dimma the idea
of the
subjugation is also designed to bring us
in if we don't accept the invitation and
we don't get killed and we are
subjugated under the the dimma the rules
for the non-muslims to live in this
state of subjugation then the idea is is
that we will see we will feel our
deprivation all the time we will be
suffering because we have rejected Islam
we will have to pay this tax we can't
have authority over Muslims we can't
build new houses of worship or repair
others we stop taking these menial jobs
because of course we can't have
authority over Muslims where we have to
get off the sidewalk if they're walking
by
because uh uh they are obviously the
superior the best of people and we can
get out of all this just by converting
to
Islam and so you see it all tends toward
bringing us in there is no compulsion in
religion and the purpose as maudi said
for which the Muslims fight is not to
force us to accept Islam it is to sub
subvert our societies and subjugate us
so that then we'll accept Islam freely
because it's so much better than living
as a a surf or essentially a slave
living without any rights whatsoever
living a precarious existence that can
be removed any time I mean that the the
the uh a precarious existance the
protection of which can be removed at
any time that's what dimma means
protection and a dii a Zumi is somebody
who is
protected and the idea of Di ude is that
we are protected in the Islamic State
but what are we protected from the
Muslims it's like the mafia you you saw
the Godfather right it's the last movie
I saw I don't get out much and uh in The
Godfather you know it's the mafia and
they uh they have a protection
racket this is they do other things too
but one of the things that you pay to
the mafia is protection money
you know you have a very nice store here
it would be a shame if something
happened to you nice picture window he
pay us a couple hundred dollar a
month I make sure nothing happens
protection but of course if you don't
pay then your windows smashed because
they're the guys that are there
protecting you
from it's the same thing with this if
you are a dii subjugated under the rule
of the Islamic State and then you go get
out of line then you're dead your
contract of protection is forfeit now
how do you how do you do that how do you
get out of
line well I'm glad you asked that
question According to Islamic
law if you say something
impermissible notice I didn't say untrue
if you say something
impermissible about Allah Muhammad Quran
Islam then no more
protection now what is impermissible
about Allah Muhammad Quran or Islam what
is
impermissible well that let's here again
don't listen to me I'm just a racist
islamophobic anti-muslim bigot let's go
to the Islamic sources and so in Islamic
law you can look it up slander what is
slander is slander telling lies about
someone not According to Islamic law
According to Islamic law you commit
slander when you say something about
someone that he does not wish to be
known and so in other words you can tell
the
truth you can say exactly what the case
is but if they don't want you to know it
then that's slander and so what is it
that they don't want us to know about
Allah Muhammad Quran or Islam well
obviously it's just the sort of things
that I'm telling you now and that's why
the people the authorities who
formulated the law in Victoria don't
know
these things because they've been lied
to and of course they've been lied to
because not only is Islam the only
religion with a Doctrine Theology and
legal system mandating Warfare against
and subjugation of unbelievers but also
Islam is the only religion with that
sanctions
deception in order to
spread and so these guys are being lied
to and if we tell the truth then that is
slander
and we lose the protection and so in
other words the authorities in Victoria
are acquiescing to the implementation of
Islamic blasphemy laws and laws that are
made for the demies for the subjugated
people that disallows them from saying
truths about Islam that are inconvenient
that they don't want known the deception
is founded on the Quran 3:28 which says
do not take unbelievers as your friends
and protectors in preference to
Believers unless you're doing it to
guard yourselves against them oh and he
who does that has nothing to do with the
law unless you're doing it to guard
yourselves against them now here again
don't believe
me Mal
dudy he says
this means that it is lawful for a
Believer helpless in the grip of the
enemies of Islam and an imminent danger
of severe wrong and persecution to keep
his faith
concealed and to behave in such a manner
as to create the impression that he's on
the same side as his
enemies to behave in such a manner as to
create the impression that he's on the
same side as his enemies but he isn't
really on
it
now clearly if Muhammad taught that he
has as he said I've been commanded to
fight against people until they confess
that there's no God but Allah and that
I'm his messenger and if the Quran says
that they have to fight us until we're
subjugated and it also says that they
can lie to us in order to protect Islam
when they feel
threatened and then we see that all our
governing authorities are listening to
Islamic authorities who tell them that
Islam is a religion of peace and has
perfectly benign intentions toward
Australia but then at the same time they
are pushing these initiatives that
always have the same feature of
asserting the Primacy of Islamic law
over our own laws and the Primacy of
Islamic customs and practices over our
own and demanding that we change the way
we do business change the way we Bank
change the way we educate our children
change the way that we maintain our
institutions in order to accommodate
them well isn't there some cognitive
dissonance there
and isn't it doesn't it just completely
dissipate and doesn't it become
completely clear what's going on as soon
as you consult the Islamic
sources and see oh oh yeah well here it
is subjugation special privileges
lying and they're falling for it just
like
that but of course all is not lost all
is not lost because after all we are
here tonight we're not in
prison and uh maybe some of us will go
later
make sure to convert to Islam to get the
good
food but
anyway I still have every confidence
that we can win this obviously our
governing authorities our law
enforcement authorities and the
mainstream media are in complete state
of
subjugation and they are letting this
initiative of stealth Jihad Gallop
forward at great speed I mean really who
would have imagined all this 10 years
ago
but at the same time we do stand for and
we are the children and Heirs of a
civilization that is superior to Islamic
civilization imagine a civilization that
does have to forbid
descent imagine how insecure that shows
you to be I mean you know if we
encounter the kind of person who bridles
at any criticism even the slightest
thing and gets angry and won't hear it
and throws you
out well we think that person is is is
rather dreadfully insecure do we not and
it's a brittle culture it's a brittle
civilization they can't stand the
slightest Challenge and so all we have
to do is challenge them and they'll
fold it's just like the schoolyard
bullies once you stand up to them you
make it a little scraped but the bullies
they're not used to resistance and
they'll just keep going and pushing and
pushing until so you push
back
now there are millions of Muslims in the
west now and many of them have come here
because they actually do prefer our
civilization that offers freedom of
speech and the freedom of conscience and
the equality of Rights of women and the
equality of Rights for
non-muslims and there are millions of
Muslims who are here because they are
muun it's a very hallowed Concept in
Islam means
immigrants and the first immigrants were
Muhammad and the early Muslims when they
left Mecca 12 years into Muhammad's
prophetic
career and moved to Medina where they
had been invited to take up residence
and Muhammad would be for the first time
a head of state and the head of an Army
and the people in Medina would convert
to Islam and so the immigrants the MU
muhajirun were the people from Mecca who
came to Medina to bring Islam to
them and it's absolutely clear that what
we have in Australia is exactly the same
phenomenon many many Muslims coming here
in order to bring Islam here not Islam
as a religion but Islam as a political
and social
order and that is part of the key to
defeating this this has all happened
because this is a
religion if Islam were a completely
secular form of political governance
that made no mention of God and did not
have a book or a prophet then this would
have been easy and it would have been
outlawed years
ago because it is an authoritarian even
totalitarian system that is absolutely
at variance with basic freedoms that we
have always enjoyed in our
societies but it's because it's a
religion and because we guarantee and
respect and rever and we should the
freedom of religion that it is Galloping
so quickly toward
hegemony but it's it's a political
entity it's a political system with a
political agenda and the more we
understand that and the more we were a
are able to communicate that to the
people that are around us who have no
clue about any of this the more we are
going to be able to bring public
pressure to bear on Islam as a political
system subject to all the scrutiny that
political entities generally
are and
that is the key to defeating it in the
United States there are 20 States I
believe it is now that have considered
anti-sharia legislation legislation to
Outlaw Islamic law and yeah it's great
except there was one state
Oklahoma uh you saw the music right um
there was one state
that while the wind came whipping down
the plane 70% of Voters voted to Outlaw
Sharia but then a judge a Clinton
appointee said no no you can't do this
it interferes with their religious
freedom and all of the anti-sharia
initiatives are stalled because of this
ruling now there's a
saying that is growing more and more
frequently repeated in the United States
and that is that the US Constitution is
not a suicide pact and the idea of
religious freedom just like all the
other constitutional guarantees is not
so absolute as to as to have to be
enforced even at the expense of the
national
interest in the 1890s as a matter of
fact the United States government
outlawed
polygamy and told the Mormon Church
which was in ut which was a territory at
the time it was applying for Statehood
and the US government told the Mormons
that they would have to Outlaw polygamy
or they would not make Utah State and
the Mormons outlawed polygamy you know
God told them it was
okay he's always changing his mind with
the
Mormons
and they outlawed polygamy and Utah was
accepted as a state and nobody was
saying oddly enough you're infringing
upon their religious freedom everyone
understood that the religious freedom
was subject to the National interest and
it becomes even more clear if Islam and
Islamic groups in Australia and in the
United States and in Europe were to be
understood as political entities and not
as religious
ones we stand
for and we enjoy in our societies a
superior set of
values one that has enabled a flowering
of the human spirit such has been
unparalleled in human
history and that is extraordinarily
attractive if we stood up for ourselves
and we stood up for who we are then also
this would not be happening it's only
because the the West in Australia in
Europe in America has suffered a massive
failure of
will that this is
happening but you know Pakistan has no
illegal immigration
problem neither does Egypt
nobody's trying to get in there people
are trying to get out and they're trying
to come where they're trying to come
here and then then here we're allowing
them to recreate how it is
there that's right and
so I think that it's useful to recall in
conclusion I'm just learning about
Australia a bit since I've been here and
wonderful country and very beautiful
place and this is a delightful City I
was walking around this morning and uh
anyway there's this money and I've been
I was asking people uh who are these
people you know and uh this is Mary
Gilmore on the 10 and it turns out Mary
Gilmore is a potius and I take it on
faith I'm way too old to read it but in
very small print here on the 10 actually
a bit of uh the poem that I'm about to
read and
uh it's uh it it sums up the situation
that we're in and the kind of spirit we
need to recover uh Dane Mary Gilmore
interesting enough was uh a
socialist I'm told and uh nowadays she
would be called a r radical right Wier
for having written this sons of the
mountains of Scotland welshmen of Kum
and defile breed of the Moors of England
children of Aaron's green aisle we stand
for square to the tempests whatever the
battering hail no foe Shall Gather our
Harvest or sit on our Stockyard rail our
women shall walk in honor
our children shall know no
chain this land that is ours Forever The
Invader shall strike at in vain Anzac to
Brook and Cota could ever the old blood
fail no foe Shall Gather our Harvest or
sit on our Stockyard
rail so thank you very much we'll take
some questions now but it's just a
matter of standing firm standing up
enforcing our own
laws being who we are and there's no
doubt in my mind that we will prevail
over this so thank you again for
coming thank you that great well we're
going to take some questions now and at
the end of question time can I just ask
you to remain seated because I'd like to
ask our president Jeff Dixon to come and
say a couple of words in conclusion as
well and uh with the questions if we can
just keep them to 30 second questions
please no statements uh hire your own
Hall if you need to do
that so just and I'll try I'll try and
watch for your hands and then I'll um so
I'll point to you and you get in so that
you probably can uh yeah can focus on
the questions so to start with we'll
take here thanks hi Robert hello welcome
thank you good day
it what do we working on it
what do we say to those when we try and
raise these issues that we everyone in
the room obviously is aware of when most
people say oh I know plenty of Muslims
they're all good people you know they're
just like us you know and they they just
and I've actually worked with some and
you you sort of have a talk with them
they say oh all that stuff it's we don't
believe in that right yeah that's the my
friend ared
syndrome my friend amed's a beautiful
guy he he's gentle soul he wouldn't hurt
a fly and I I I go to his house for
Christmas
and wonderful guy so all everything
you're saying must be
false my friend Ahmed
fallacy there is in Islam a spectrum of
belief and knowledge and fervor among
the adherence of the religion just as
there is in Christianity Judaism or
anything else and as a matter of fact
every human society is characterized by
people who adhere very much and it means
everything to them the beliefs of the of
the religion or the beliefs of the party
or the organizational goals or whatever
and they know all about it and they can
explain it and defend it and they love
it and they live by it and then there
are others who couldn't care less but if
you ask them they'll say we I guess I'm
a Christian yeah but they haven't
darkened the door of a church in years
and and they don't you know or uh maybe
Christmas and Easter and it's the same
thing in Islam there are people who know
all about it and care very much there
are people who don't know anything about
it and don't care there is every great
aan in between those
two and so you
cannot extrapolate from the individual
that you might meet really anything
about Islamic teaching or Islamic
theology or Islamic goals in the in in
in in Australia or the United States
the individual may not be tied into that
at
all uh but that doesn't mean it doesn't
exist you know the Catholic Church says
that it's a sin to practice artificial
contraception about 70% of Catholics
according to polls practice artificial
contraception does that mean the church
doesn't teach that no it just means most
people ignore it Islam all the sects and
schools of Islam teach that it's part of
the responsibility of Muslims to wage
war against and subjugate unbel
Believers you will probably meet Muslims
who couldn't care less about that may
not even know about it and are going
about their lives does that mean that
Islam does not teach Jihad Warfare
against unbelievers unfortunately that
would be a f fallacious
conclusion oh thank you well I'll go
onesided yes uh good I good night was
that better good
night uh Rob do you you think or perhaps
believe um the Occupy is part of the
stealth Gad occupy do I think that
occupy is part of the stealth Jihad yes
and no uh occupy is a useful idiot it's
a tool uh the leftists and the Islamic
supremacists are good friends and close
allies and they have worked together for
years and people find this odd and
people ask me about this all the time
you know don't they know that they're
going to kill homosexuals and don't they
know that they're going to close the
clubs and outlaw alcohol and all that
and you know these people are leftists
what what are they thinking
well I think that in the first place
there is a very deep connection that
they actually do
have it is a marriage of convenience it
it is a case where probably both sides
think they can use the other and discard
it once they're through with their
immediate goal which is to defeat us
those that is the Guardians and
Defenders of Western
Civilization however uh my friend Jamie
glazov who's the editor of front page
magazine which I highly recommend front
pag magazine.com uh he wrote a book
United in hate which I also highly
recommend for this question it's about
this leftist jihadist Alliance and He
suggests and I think he's really on to
something here that there's actually a
deep ideological kinship between the
left and Islam because they both
Envision an Earthly Utopia established
by A Reign of Terror whenever the hardle
has gotten into Power you know Stalin ma
Paul pot all the rest of
them they have instituted A Reign of
Terror I'm not I'm not going to say
anything about that and they've
instituted A Reign of
Terror that in a slow motion way
parallels Sharia Islamic law which also
rules by
Terror that is you know stoning
amputation the death penalties for this
and that and the doctrines of warfare
and you you're afraid you know there's
not it's people often think especially
uh religious conservatives often think
well you know these people at least
they're moral and we we we should we
should have make an alliance with them
on the basis that we're we're both moral
people against secularism but actually
Islamic morality is very Hollow it's
based on fear it's not really the
cultivation of virtue and doing the
right thing because it's the right thing
this is doing the right thing so you
don't get your hand chopped off
and in any case you see the connection
that both of
them have the same idea in mind that
they will establish the just Society on
Earth the perfect Society on Earth and
anybody who gets out of line will will
get it will be done violence too and so
there is a connection between the the
goals of the two
thank you over the yes um um good day
good day good
day the rain in Spain sorry I have a
question about reverts reverts
especially um I guess women um young
women like whenever I watch the the
YouTube videos of people who've rted
they all kind of say the same thing you
know like I read and I studied the Quran
and it just all made sense and I'm like
can stuff yeah is are they groomed and
what part of the Quran makes sense
to
okay in the first place let's talk about
reverts the question was uh what is it
about reverts that uh they they they all
say the same thing and that is that they
read the Quran and it all made sense and
what part of the Quran makes sense now
first things first
revert every convert to Islam as you
probably know is called a revert by the
Muslims because the Islamic Doctrine is
that we're all Muslims and the original
religion of all the prophets and all the
biblical figures is Islam and that
we fell away and that our forefathers
they twisted and hijacked the teachings
of the Muslim prophets like Abraham
Moses and Jesus to create what we know
of today is Judaism and
Christianity and so
everybody who converts to Islam is
called a
revert I would suggest with all respect
that we not use this this kind of
terminology because we don't believe
that everybody was originally a Muslim
and so I'm going to talk from now on
about converts to Islam not reverts but
I understand what you're saying now
converts to Islam often say very often
that they read the Quran and it all made
sense and everything fell into place now
there's couple things you have to
understand about converts to Islam they
get lied to just like everybody
else Islam has a doctrine of deception
and I actually have a uh a very good
friend who was a convert to Islam and he
was a very prominent convert to Islam as
a matter of fact uh and he left Islam
although he has not left Islam publicly
because Islam also has a death penalty
for apostasy and even in the United
States of America in Washington DC in
2011 he knows that if he comes out and
says he's not a Muslim he's going to
have to watch his back and so he is not
a public convert to Islam from Islam but
he's very uh very helpful fellow because
he's tied into all the Islamic advocacy
groups he's all their friends and he
sends me their
emails but
anyway
he has written actually even while he
was a Muslim about the disparity the
disconnect between what he was told
Islam was all about and what he found
out it was all about when he got
in and there is actually a manual of daa
of Islamic prizing that I have in my
office that uh come on over I'll show it
to you and U it says that the potential
converts are to be given a partial and
concocted view of
Islam and then once they get in you
introduce them to the quote
revolutionary aspect of Muhammad's uh
teaching and so they all they they they
hear some things that may make sense
because of course Islam of course to
Black American converts potential
converts is pitched as the religion is
free of racism and the churches have a
very poor racial record in the US but
Islam is free of all that and
Brotherhood and equality and everything
they don't tell you about the Arab
supremacism you find out about that
later
and what about the Quran makes sense
well that's another thing that my friend
the uh former convert told me is that
that he was he didn't actually read the
Quran before he went in but he was one
of those guys saying I read the Quran
and it all made sense he read pieces
that they gave him and then when he
actually sat down and read it cover to
cover he said he was extraordinarily
disappointed he just kept waiting for
the wisdom to show
up actually in the Arabic it's even
worse because about every fifth sentence
doesn't really make
sense and uh that's the subject part of
the subject of my next book which will
be out in a few months I used to say in
the spring and then I found out that was
now um the uh it'll be out in a few
months and it is called did Muhammad
exist and in it I I examine the uh the
historical foundations of early Islam
and actually they're quite shaky and one
of the things that makes them shaky is
that the Quran is so scrambled and
Confused in many ways
and contains so many neologisms and
Oddities of grammar and strange
statements that nobody knows what what
it's talking about and there are uh some
Scholars who have done some really
fascinating work in this Regard in uh I
don't know if you know how Arabic works
but Arabic letters are most of them 16
of them are identical to at least one
other letter in the alphabet in shape
except for the diacritical marks the
dots that go above or below but the
earliest qurans don't have those dots
and so some people are having stripped
out the diacritical marks that are part
of the canonical text of the Quran are
examining it and saying well what else
could this mean and finding a very
interesting Aramaic Christian substratum
it seems that it was some sort of an
Aramaic Christian text that was
repointed as part of the uh e efforts of
the early Arab empires to create this
religion that would give cohesiveness to
that Empire
so anyway stay tuned for that it'll be
at any self-respecting
bookstore March or April anyone
Miss oh yes I'm not picking back there
yes you um what questions to
ums don't want you to ask about
their I'm sorry could you repeat the
question what what questions to Muslims
don't want you ask about their faith oh
what questions do Muslim Muslims not
want you to ask about their faith well
bearing in mind that they'll lie they'll
take any
question uh but Islamic spokesmen will
not usually be honest with you if you
ask them about the doctrine of deception
they'll say it's a it's a Shiite thing
that taka which means covering it's also
the name of the uh the head covering the
little hat you know that looks like a
doily um the
the doctrine of deception was actually
formally developed by the Shiites who
are the minority in the in Islam they're
about 15% of Muslims worldwide and they
were ferociously persecuted by the
sunnis uh throughout all of Islamic
history and today and so they developed
this doctrine of deception that they
could lie and say they were Sunni and
conceal their Shiite identity uh in
order to escape persecution and that's
what
you will get from Islamic spokesmen if
you ask them about this doctrine of
deception and they'll say then they'll
probably be Sunni because they are most
Muslims and they'll say we reject that
we don't have that that's just a Shiite
aberration but the problem is it's in
the Quran as I quoted to you and there's
another passage chapter 16 ver 101 that
I did not quote I gave you 328 which
says you can not take Bel not take
unbelievers as in preference to
Believers as your friends and protectors
unless you're doing it to guard
yourselves against them and you see that
there's another uh Islamic Authority who
who explains that verse by saying we
smile in the face of some people but
behind their backs we curse
them anyway there's another verse 16101
which says that uh uh If you deny your
faith if you're a Muslim and you deny
that you're a Muslim you'll go straight
to Hell unless you're in grave danger
and then you can pretend that you're not
a Muslim so in any case that's one
another one would be about the doctrines
of warfare and they'll tell you that the
doctrines of warfare were restricted to
the time of Muhammad and that that verse
that I quoted to you 929 that says fight
against the unbelievers fight against
even the people of the book until they
pay the jizu with willing submission and
feel themselves subdued they'll say that
only has to do with the people of the
book who were in Medina at Muhammad's
time but in the first place that's total
nonsense it makes no sense that
uh the verse would only apply to the
people of the book of Muhammad's time
and none thereafter because Muhammad
himself in a Hadith he says be sure to
collect the gizia because it is the
source of livelihood for yourselves and
your
descendants and most Islamic authorities
when they interpret the Quran when they
are explaining the Quran to Muslims they
say that the passages that are from
Medina the later part of Muhammad's
career take precedence over the earlier
chronologically and unfortunately for us
the passages that do enjoin Warfare
against us including that one 929 come
in at the latter part of Muhammad's
career so According to Islamic theology
they take precedence over the
earlier this is that's the mainstream
View
also one would have to wonder about why
a perfect and eternal book would be
revealed in which large portions of it
only apply to 7th Century conditions
that will presumably never be
repeated when it's supposed to be the
guide for human behavior for all time
and so uh these are very common things
that you'll hear from Islamic spokesman
and I could go on and on but those are
two where it's not that they won't like
the question they just won't tell you
the truth about the about it and uh if
you ever do get to ask uh Muslims
spokesman the question I will bet you
100 bucks that the answers that I just
gave you will be the answers that you'll
get from
them yes Robert thank you very much for
everything you are doing help
yes would it help the cause if tonight
we were to vote on a resolution and to
pick one at random Australia's IM
migration policy should be designed for
the benefit of Australia and therefore
we require an indef and indefinite
moratorium on Islamic immigration now
that's just one of many possibilities
but would it help the cause if you were
to invite us to propose such resolutions
and vote on them and record the
result well it would be great but I'm
not quite sure I understand you mean if
the Q Society or the people at the Q
society meeting voted on this resolution
or if we were able to Prevail Upon Our
governing authorities to accept it well
all I'm suggesting is that when so many
good people are together yes and Sim and
thanks to yourself generally of one mind
uh the impact of that of such a
gathering is uh invariably more profound
if there's an expression of the view of
the Gathering oh well I don't have any
objection to that certainly but I would
like to see rather more the that's more
for society yes I'd like to see
uh that introduced as something that
would actually be considered by
legislators uh and that would be of
course all to the good because uh it's
not that every Muslim is bringing this
program to Australia as I explained
before but there's no way to distinguish
the ones who are from the ones who
aren't and so any kind of moratorium
like that would be certainly in the
National interest the problem is that
both Australia and the US are ruled Now
by internationalists who don't have the
national interests of the country as
their first priority there are many
other opportunities for example fale
genital mutilation is something that is
absolutely rejected by
Society thank you um actually
you um just a quick question obviously
uh our politicians uh capitulation on
what we were just discussing is a major
problem um what kind of advice speak up
please up it'll be repeated it'll be
what kind of advice would you give us as
people to try to get our influence our
politicians to wake up to this where are
you from H Canada oh
hello yeah I can't do the good day
either
up
uh obviously the capitulation of our
politicians is a major problem what can
we do about it fair summation well vote
them out and put them in
jail oh of course it is so so the first
thing we have to do is raise awareness
the problem that we face in the fact
that these quizzing are ruling our
countries is that there aren't enough of
our fellow citizens who are aware of
this problem and so the absolute first
foundational thing we have to do is
raise awareness and there is every
opportunity that we have to do that you
are going to encounter people tomorrow
in your work in your school whatever you
are going to encounter people who think
that it would be mad for you to be
here and who think that you might be a
racist yes did I actually and you have a
chance to explain these things and a
responsibility to do
so we are the soldiers in this war there
is no other group and no other
individual who is going to do this for
us we have to do it this is not a
conventional War the army is not going
to help the government is obviously not
going to help the media is not going to
help who's that leave us we have to do
it every
day try to think of something that you
can do that you would not otherwise have
done something that you can do to
preserve this Republic and to defend it
and to preserve the values of our
civilization and there are numerous
opportunities will unfold before you but
mostly it will be simply about trying to
convince somebody else who does not have
a clue and once we gain critical mass
then we'll be able to affect political
change and see the thing is it's going
to happen because the more they push the
more people wake up every time they win
they lose when they get special
accommodations somewhere when there's
some crazy decision made by some crazy
judge to allow them special privileges
that others do not have
more people wake up yeah and they are
our friends and allies we have to find
them bring them to the Q Society bring
them in and make them
work yes down the back
there um I've chatted you a few times on
Facebook and I've reposted probably
hundreds of your Jihad watch blogs um
the problem I'm and I think a lot of
people here are having is uh I'm out to
suggest how wake the younger crowd up
younger generation to what's going on
because as you can imagine most their
20s and early
[Music]
30s we' just had a few yes yes uh the
question is about how do we wake young
people up and I can't say actually last
was it when was it now and where um um
if it Tuesday in Sydney if it was
Tuesday it must have been Sydney and
they there were there were there was a
good group of young people there and
there was one who was not with them who
was there to uh challenge me and uh we
had some fun and there were others
however who were completely energized
about this and so I offer that to you as
a sign of hope that uh you're not alone
and there are others and uh meanwhile at
the same time the it's the the answer to
your question is the same as the answer
to the general question of how you wake
anybody up that they're not going to see
it until they see how it impinges upon
them yeah and so you can bring that
about you can start to point out to your
friends and allies things about uh
alcohol and things about clubs you know
there was that uh that uh Australian was
it
Bena who said that when we have Sharia
in Australia then alcohol will be
outlawed and we're going to close down
all these
clubs and so show that to them and say
see you know I'm not making this up this
is this is a matter of concern oh it'll
never happen well then show them how
it's happening show them what's being
done but it's an educational thing and
we all have to be the
Educators um yes thank you good evening
Rob Bill b good evening I have a
proposal to offer to you to your
consideration uh you mentioned during
your talk that this is all happening
because Islam is a religion you also
mentioned in how many ways it's not
really a religion as we know a religion
um as a long-term strategy it might s
seem a bit oversimplified but one way to
push the bully back why don't we take
the measures necessary in each Western
Society to D Islam as a religion it then
has no protection as a religion and
becomes a political organization why
don't we take measures in Western
Society to deregister Islam as a
religion and remove its protections
there from such that it is of by default
a political organization um I certainly
have no objection in principle to
attempting to do that of course um
that's not going to happen in the
current political climate and also I'm a
bit uncomfortable with it only because
Islam is a religion and I know there are
a lot of people around who like to say
Islam is not a religion but it is a
religion a religion if you look it up
what is a religion a religion is
something a system of beliefs that
purports to relate mankind to God and
Islam does that so Islam is a religion
but you're quite right that Islam is not
a religion in the way that we think of
religions and it is much more than a
religion and it the more that it is is
political and supremacist and so
certainly we need
to classify Islam as a political entity
in in our
countries and if that can be done by
declassifying it as a religion I I'm
certainly I'm going to stand in the way
but I think that it's it opens us up to
a
vulnerability uh of attacks from the
opposition saying well obviously these
people are nuts because Islam is a
religion and so it's better to say Islam
is a religion and also a political
entity with a political agenda that is
inimical to our rights and freedoms and
so as a result we have to classify it as
such thank you yes um you mentioned the
the
correspondence
in between the hard left and and the the
political Jihad the fact they got
something coming what about what about
the soft play um which of course is more
of a problem in in Western societies and
this um what seems to be a
um the use of one religion as a way to
tear down Christianity as a way to tear
down the judaic Christian Heritage we've
got a group of infidels already are
basically the political class in the
society and they have this huous and
arrogance which says that all religions
will collapse
because of the superiority of the
atheistic or agnostic View and they
cannot see the possibility of any other
of any other outcome isn't this a
fundamental fundamental problem they
will they will use every weapon
including ISL to attack our what you
were talking about us as as the
inheritors of this of the greatest um
culture culture we say oh yeah
absolutely the the
uh soft left is the subject of the uh
observations
and
the idea why is it that the the the
political left in our countries the more
mainstream left why are they alive I
spoke about the heart left before and
the reign of terror and so on well
actually I touched on it briefly uh the
reason for the alliance and it's just
exactly what you're saying I think
that's because that's the objective the
object is the destruction of uh
judeo-christian tradition and the
destruction of the right in Australia
and in the United States and in Europe
and they think because they
underestimate the power of religious
appeals they really don't take Islam
seriously but they see that these people
are set against the West so they can use
them and then they think they'll be able
to take care them
easily I think they're going to be
rudely awakened in that regard but the
Alliance has been revelatory we see that
with the feminists we found out now
everyone ought to know here that the
feminist movement doesn't really care
about women at all because if it did it
would be at the Forefront of fighting
against genital mutilation and honor
killing and the subjugation of women by
polygamy and all the other elements of
Islam that restrict women's freedom and
rights but they don't as a matter of
fact I've written several articles you
can find in the Jihad watch Archives of
profiling feminists who actually defend
these
things and oh sure and who say that it's
that the Muslim women they they like
they're happy in this wearing this thing
and being subject to men in these ways
and so you can't say anything about it
and of course that's never a courtesy
that they accorded to Western women in
the 1960s didn't matter if they were
happy or not not having a job and and
being in the home and so on uh and so we
see that the real objective of the
feminists is not to defend women at all
but what trumps that is this shared
common desire to destroy Western
Civilization I refer to the Q Society
hand out on halal food and
certification here it says that half of
the beef in Australia in shops and
supermarkets is already Halal
logistically how does that occur as per
the definition of Halal in this handout
in a mass beef production facility that
usually gets a bu through the head in
Australia do you have all these people
standing around slitting throats hanging
the animal up and saying the prayer
technically explain the process so it's
just explain the process of Halal how
it's done uh well it does yeah you do
slit the uh Thro of the animal and
Islamic prayers are said that's how it's
done how it's done in a mass production
environment I do not know uh I uh I'm
sorry that I haven't studied meat
packing but uh I would expect that uh
yeah it's that the slitting of the
throat is done in a machine way and I do
actually know because I've just been
involved in a controversy about this at
the United States that the uh Islamic
prayers are not pronounced over every
individual animal but over lots of them
and uh so that's one thing that speeds
up the process um as far as
the statistic it's absolutely accurate
and there's actually probably it's
higher because um the meat packing
industry in the United States as well is
uh apparently operating according to the
principle that well the Muslims care
about this and nobody else does and so
we'll just make all the meat
halal
and doing it now a lot of it is out
there it's Halal and it's not labeled as
such and so people with a religious
objection or an animal cruelty objection
or an objection simply because the Halal
certification is probably done by groups
with ties to Jihad Terror groups people
who object to it on whatever grounds uh
have to stand up and demand that the
meat be properly labeled and why should
50% of Australian uh meat be Halal 50%
of Australians aren't Muslim I don't
have any objection to Halal meat being
available as long as there's an
alternative could I just direct
certainly yeah um just if You' like to
have a chat to Jeff at the end if you're
interested in that because he's done a
lot of research into Halal in Australia
and also there's a website Halal
choices.com and there's a a lady kly
Smith in Sydney who's done a lot of
research into and you get information
from there too but it's for another time
that question but C je
afterwards oh
um aough one uh how how do you respond
to claims that the perceived inherited
Primacy of um the Jewish culture is not
or is barely different to that which
you're assigning to the Islamic culture
I'm sorry can you repeat the question so
how would you respond to claims this is
the kind of question my friends are
going to ask me yes uh that the
perceived inherited pracy of the jewi
culture in the judeo Christian perceived
inherited pracy yeah like about the
Islamic culture believe they are there's
a promise they
have they're the best of people
correct claims that that is no different
to oh it's extraordinarily different yes
I understand that so maybe highlight
three things that you could show me that
absolutely absolutely the question is
how is the uh idea that the Muslims have
that they're better than everybody else
different from the idea that the Jews
have is that is that a fair summation or
you know judeo
Christian you know wear an
inherit okay well in the first place if
you're talking about from the standpoint
of moral relativism and saying that all
cultures are equal then consider that if
one takes that to its uh logical
conclusion then World War II would never
have been fought and Hitler would be the
master of Europe and we might be
speaking German now because you can't
judge the Nazis that's their
culture and so if your friends are
simply moral relativists then that's
that's easy obviously they don't operate
as moral relativists in the world today
uh obviously they take for granted a
certain set of values that involve
things that are very like the Ten
Commandments and they probably take
umage at people who kill commit adultery
steal and so on and these things are
manifestations of the fact that human
beings are indeed constituted in a
particular way and and and have a moral
compass whatever their belief system may
be and so to say that uh something is
just as every culture is just as good as
every other is to allow for monstrous
evils that uh have been perpetrated by
various cultures and to judge them as
just the same as cultures that do not
perpetrate those monstrous evils that's
one thing but if you're talking about at
the same time the uh the idea of a
chosen people and the idea that the Jews
are the chosen people that's very
different from the Muslim idea that the
Muslims are the best of people the Jews
understand and the Christians also
believe that the Jews are chosen by God
in a particular
way and yet there is no hint anywhere
especially in the Jewish scriptures the
old Testament nothing in there that
would suggest that the Jews believe
themselves to be better human beings
than non-jews as a matter of fact there
quite quite a bit to the contrary
because the Jews are so
self-critical and honest
about their failings that the their own
scriptures and their self-critical
nature has been used against
them by Christian antisemites and by
Muslims and the Muslims routinely
actually even to this day speak about
the Jews as the killers of the prophets
and so on and so on and they're
reflecting Islamic Traditions that were
taken over from Judaism itself about the
Jews being nasty to their own prophets
so the idea of chosenness is a matter of
a responsibility but it does not confer
upon them in their own understanding any
actual superiority of any kind whereas
in Islam the superiority is is Frank
it's open and it's foundational it's
right there chapter 3: 110 of the Quran
you are the best of people whereas the
unbelievers are the most vile of created
beings and so it's two separate things
and so I hope that uh that covers it but
if if they're just relativists well
that's just sort of nonsensical and if
they're worried about the other that's
that's another one you can
ask yes Vicki
sorry uh just a comment uh to help you I
have written this uh little uh critique
of learning from one another that's book
Muslim prepared by Muslims for our
primary and high school it's 50 pages it
will give you sufficient information to
debunk Islam you you'll find it very
helpful thank you thank you
yes
um America Europe and Australia we've
always felt ourselves Defenders of democ
Y and always pushing um that agenda Wass
in the in in Iraq and Afghanistan
pushing that um you've highlighted
several flaws with democracy in being
able to defend itself against Islam and
in Europe we see uh in governments
importing Muslims as ready voters and
obviously legislation getting pushed
through uh Democratic courts allowing uh
furthering of Islam would you consider
that democracy is fundamentally
incapable of Defending itself against
Islam or all the contrary no I I don't
think democracy is incapable of
Defending itself against Islam at all I
think that uh what we see in the
initiatives that you outlin is more the
function of the moral relativism that I
was discussing for the last question and
that uh the Guardians of our democracies
have lost their moral compass and their
values and lost their appreciation for
our own culture they
swear you must do that here right they
Swear to protect the nation and to
uphold its laws and then they betray
it and so if they simply if did what
they pledged they would do then these
things would never go
through and most of the stealth Jihad
initiatives are not a matter of uh
people voting by majority for the
initiative at itself it is uh something
that's mixed in with something else that
they're voting for or it's done uh
undercover of darkness and
deception uh I I have every confidence
that the vast majority of Australians
and I'm talking about 90% or more would
stand with us if they really realized
what was going
on and so I actually have a have a great
faith in the Dem Democratic process and
if we can get the word out and if we can
break the mainstream media Monopoly on
information then people will flock to
this cause and democracy will be the
salvation of Australia and the United
States in Europe what about um existing
uh countries in the Middle East for
instance recently there are elections in
Iraq and George Bush was credited with
saying that um if the Iraqi people vote
him an Islamic government then that is
the will of the people and that is
democracy but when you say that when
democracy is unable to deliver liberty
and
justice then it is fundamentally flawed
like what happens when the majority is
Muslim when they reach that
51% and then it is the will of the
people uh what then yeah you're quite
right the democracies of Australia
United States western Europe they were
formulated by people who had deeply em
bibed the judeo-christian tradition even
if they were not Believers
themselves they were working from
judeo-christian
values and they understood that the
majority of the populists shared those
values you know when they put freedom of
religion into the First Amendment to the
US
Constitution I am sure that nobody had
in mind
a radically repressive and repaci
totalitarian ideology that was going to
eat up all the other religions and uh uh
spit them
out nobody had nobody envisioned that
they were talking about methodists and
Baptists and Presbyterians living side
by side with not one of them having the
upper
hand and
so democracy transplanted to the Middle
East you know George Bush he uh he he
criticized those who said never work
like me he he he didn't name me by name
but he said uh he hasn't returned my
calls either and uh he said that you
know they said that it wouldn't work in
Germany and Japan after World War II and
yet we brought democracy and they are
shining democracies
today
and I do that one better
no but the thing about Germany in Japan
is that the ideologies that had fueled
the militarism in both countries were
defeated were prostrate after the war
yeah whereas in Iraq Islam was the fuel
of the militarism and it was not
prostrated as a matter of fact it was
encouraged the the United States oversaw
and underwrote and financed the
implementation of Islamic law of sharia
as the highest law of the land in the
Constitutions of both Iraq and
Afghanistan that is a fundamentally
anti-democratic
system that denies I mean you can't have
democracy without freedom of speech and
disent and you can't have democracy
where significant elements of the
population are
disenfranchised so the whole thing was
self-contradictory and in a place where
most of the people believe that's the
law of the Supreme Being not to be
questioned and Superior to any man-made
law then obviously there's no way that a
western style Republic could ever take
root what do you think's and so I don't
I I I'm not saying that democracy at all
costs has to be pursued as a matter of
fact those are states with authoritarian
Traditions they've never had anything
but authoritarian rulers and so whatever
authoritarian ruler they have if he
allows for the the the non-muslims of
the world and of his country to live in
relative peace and stability that might
be all we can ask for but to to to spend
millions and billions and blood and
treasure and men and material and all
sorts of things to try to make
Afghanistan into uh Palm Beach it's just
never going to happen no no
okay one more one more question one
more okay at the back
there Robert do you think uh with the
cops in Egypt that we are looking down
the barrel of another Holocaust yes do I
think with the cops in Egypt were
looking down the barrel of another
Holocaust most certainly U the Arab
Spring is really an Islamic winter
they're imposing Islamic law uh the
Muslim Brotherhood won the elections as
expected they're going to uh try to
transform Egypt into an Islamic State I
expect it will fold out unfold much the
way it did in Iran in the 70s when the
Sha was uh betrayed by Jimmy Carter and
he fell and the Ayatollah came in with
an alliance a coalition with leftist
groups and one by one he killed them all
imprisoned them all and eventually uh
laid the foundations for the Islamic
Republic and now the Muslim brotherhoods
talking about a coalition with leftist
groups the same thing is playing out
exactly and This spells disaster for the
cops because they have been resisting it
and because they had
relative equality of rights under the
Arab nationalist regimes of Nasser and
then Sadat and then Mubarak for the last
50 years and now it these the
responsibility remember I said this
during the talk of the Muslims to make
sure they feel themselves
subdued and they have not been subdued
and so now they're going to get it and
so yes the the real Scandal here is that
the world community and the so-called
human rights apparatus uh doesn't pain
any attention they couldn't care less if
it's Christians because uh Christians
are from the big bad West that dominates
the world and oppresses everybody else
and so if some non-white non-western
Christians get killed well really it's
all it's all George Bush's fault anyway
and so it doesn't
matter I mean I don't holding much brief
for George Bush but this is the kind of
way that they think and that they talk
anyway thank you so much for coming
fight never give up never give in
thank you very much let get our
president Jeff Dixon to come in and
thank Robert and uh I just wanted to
mention a couple of things we didn't get
uh stealth ghad Robert's book it didn't
arrive in time but if you want to order
it there will be 20 copies of it coming
to Brisbane so see Jeff about that uh
he's also got a little book at the back
Michael's holding up called islamophobia
it's only $5 and it's a great little
read if and that's uh through uh one of
Robert's little booklets um and also
when we